[موسيقى]
اولا تبقى
معديه يا جماعه هيكس
[موسيقى]
ب كانت التوقعات تشير الى اجتماع ضروري
للبنك المركزي استثنائي نظرا لان الاجتماع
المجدول له في الثاني والعشرين من ديسمبر
الحالي كانت التوقعات قبل انعقاد المجلس
التنفيذي للصندوق لمناقشه الاتفاق مع مصر
ان يكون هناك اجتماعيه وذلك في ضوء
الاتسال هو ما بين السعر الرسمي والسعر
غير الرسمي
للجنيه المصري واحد شروط الصندوق ان يتكون
هناك مرور اكبر لسعر الصرف في السوق وهذا
غير متوفر حاليا
[موسيقى]
اي تحريك لسعر العمله في الوقت الحالي
بالضبط سيؤدي الى تسال هو اكبر بين السعر
الرسم وغير رسمي وذلك هدوء عدم وجود
السيوله دولاريه في في مصر السوق يعاني من
سحب السيوله الدوريه وبالتالي من الافضل
ان يتم الانتظار حين موافقه الصندوق على
الاتفاق وبالتالي حصول مصر على الشريحه
الاولى التي تقدر بنحو 750 مليون دولار
[موسيقى]